foreign
[Music]
shows you just how devastating the
effects of Russian bombing of this city
has been
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
but for people to be stopping the Convoy
coming from the hospital throwing roses
at her casket it's hard to put words to
with every Palestinian is feeling today
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
this fire is happening all across this
part of Spain but these Flames represent
the kind of change in the profile of
these wildfires the last three rainy
seasons have failed and so this is
what's happened to many of the animals
drought has reduced these famous marshes
in some areas to puzzles and that's
damaging the lives of the people the
wildlife and ecosystems millions of
pakistanis at the risk of floods and
drought are afraid that the world will
once again forget about them until
another Monsoon on steroids hits them
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
Argentina has won the World Cup and
people here are promising to celebrate
for a very long time